now the ESPY aren't the only nationalist
party standing in the general election
in wales voters have the option of
voting for playa camry as well and their
leader Adam price is here thank you very
much for being with us today now you of
course are the self-styled party for
Wales how can you really say that that's
what you are when you're not even
standing in every seat because you're
standing aside for some people in this
remain alliance are you well you know I
think when you when you believe that as
we clearly do that the choice that we're
about to make in the next few weeks
whether we continue to leave or whether
we stay within the European Union we
think remaining is absolutely critically
important to our economy recovery sector
manufacturing sector love a heart ripped
out of a Welsh economy if we leave on
the basis of either Labour's brake City
or the Tories paroxetine the right thing
to do is to maximise that remain voice
in the next parliament and if we if but
if I'm working together with other Pro
remain parties we can actually defend
Wales is interest and will always put
Wales before party it's interesting
isn't because at the same time Wales
voted to leave the EU when you talking
about its kind of maximizing the remain
mode but some of those lis voters and
Wales might see this as basically a bit
of a stitch-up
I talked about that those leaving voters
on a daily basis you know I have some of
them within my own community my own
family and you know thank you that yeah
there are there are as many different
reasons as to why people voted leave as
there are leave voters but I think some
of it was a deep sense of exasperation
you know particularly at Westminster
politics and that's probably got even
worse over the last three and a half
years has we gone round and round in
circles and when we look at the state of
will sort the poverty the endemic
poverty $200,000 children living in
poverty you know it hasn't changed
generation by generation Labour
government Conservative government it's
always been the same and I think part of
the reason of the whole of the reason
for everyone we're part of the reason
that people voted leave because they
want to change right unfortunately the
change that's on offer through brexit
won't deliver the economic justice the
people who else want will only happen if
Wales finds its voice at this election
if we elect the biggest Evan number of
Wales's party pride Camry MPs at
Westminster then whoever's in Downing
Street you know jangling those keys and
Friday 13th is M but we'll have to
listen to whales like they've never done
before you're talking about having
conversations with Lee voters including
someone your own family do you have
family arguments father stuffin well I
think it's true everywhere isn't it I'm
Wales is divided as area the part of the
country but by the there's question I
you know I think it's important to
actually respect each other you know you
can civilly disagree we haven't seen
enough of that anything in politics
recently I understand you know people
sincerely disagree in terms of the
brexit issue but look I think that we
have to ask the the the bigger question
as well is how are we going to get
change in in Wales look how are we going
to move with a position where we've been
bumping along at the bottom of the
economic league table for you know four
generations we've got a Labour
government in in Cardiff they had for
twenty years you know that hasn't
actually changed things that's why you
know I say to people the key the key
message look putting your faith in the
Westminster parties has never delivered
change for Wales it won't deliver it at
this election are either you know labour
in Wales is in government it's it's not
part of the solution it's part of the
problem look at the problems in our NHS
in Wales they mirror exactly they
actually are A&E waiting times await
worse in ways look at the the scandal in
terms of maternity services income
Tophet said right don't put your faith
in the in the Westminster parties
they'll never deliver for Wales let's
put our faith in in ourselves that's the
only way that we'll get justice and
change four wheels if we start to vote
for our own party talking about and you
know putting faith in Wales and voting
for your own party rather than the
Westminster parties are you not worried
that by doing effectively deals with
parties who were against Welsh
independence you're just prioritizing
brexit above independence it's not the
calculation of how well look this was an
election was precipitated in the brexit
crisis so there was always going to be a
dominant issue and it is huge
implications for Wales and we have to we
have to be honest you know when people
ask me you know he's gonna help Wales oh
he's gonna do it was it is gonna hurt
this like and I saw in my father was a
minor right thrown on that the slag keep
in the 1980s you know I've seen what the
industrialization can do to Wales I
don't want to see any other family going
through what we experienced in the 1980s
if there's any opportunity of halting it
look we're starting a new decade in
about six weeks time right I want to see
where's rising up that economic league
table what we don't want to do is the
harm ourselves so we're actually two
steps going two steps backwards we need
to be going forwards as a country we've
got great potential you know we were at
the cradle of the old industrial
revolution we could be there with a
green industrial revolution we've got
fantastic natural resources or off our
shores in terms of wind and wave energy
etc let's grasp that opportunity and not
see this brexit which won't deliver
anything four wheels you know harming us
let's get investment I mean I noticed
the Labour Party's manifesto they were
offering a hand over a hundred billion
they claimed the Scotland nothing like
that for where's why because Wales
doesn't matter to the Westminster
parties you know we are peripheral to
the political agenda of Westminster and
the only way we can change that is if
Wales finds his voice and votes for
Wales his party of this election you
think that Labour is part of the problem
Nicola Sturgeon has made it very clear
that she would potentially work with
Jeremy Corbyn in order to get him into
number 10 rather than Boris Johnson
what's your position on that
of course I mean we were trying to
impeach Boris Johnson a few weeks ago I
don't want to see Boris Johnson as Prime
Minister but neither do I think that
simply installing a Labour government is
going to change things either unless and
until we have a strong voice for Wales
Wales his party represented there all
those all those promises that they're
offering fewer to Wales than Scotland of
course what would you do would you would
you just not have any talks at all with
with labour if there's a hung parliament
or would you just go in there and and
have some pretty clear red lines what's
the position what we've said is that the
best leverage possible is if we have the
strongest bloc applied Camery MPs in our
history and that's on the cards but by
the way and then hold them to account
you know use our influence on a vote by
vote case by case basis so they have to
come knocking on our door on
door every day of the next parliament
you know we have a work one Welsh day in
Westminster at the moment I want every
day in Westminster to be a Welsh day
because Wales has found its voice what
would be a good night well good night
we'll be having the strongest greatest
number of you know local champion well
I'd realistically look I mean III think
that the important thing is that we have
that the best night ever in our history
not just for our party but that'll make
the headlines what did you'll be talking
about Wales along with all the other
political programs which I won't mention
because we'll be on the agenda take a
look
you know Wales the the the sleeping
giant that is that is the dragon you
know is rising and we won't just have
red lines you were asking the cluster
German red lines will have red white and
green lines because the Welsh flag will
be there in Westminster like never
before we're running out of time but
there's one question that I'm keen just
to ask us about a recent interview that
you gave where you said that well should
get reparation for a century of neglect
we can just have a quick look at the
quote that you gave it in this interview
and you said I feel very strongly that
it's not possible to understand the
predicament we're in without
acknowledging the centrality the fact
that we had an extra tip economy with a
political power center outside of our
nation and then you went on to say for
most people that is analogous if not
identical to the experience of
colonialism
now there's some people who've taken
offense of this this comparison with
cloning and what would you say to that
when I first got elected as an MP Sophie
and I was canvassing in my own valley
right I knocked on door after door and I
saw - my work with my father some of
them right strong men that couldn't get
up from the chair they were wearing
oxygen masks you know and in that image
you know that is the story of Wales you
know a country that was rich in natural
resources that was plundered the wealth
was squandered you know forget about
forget about trickle-down economics none
of that money that you know the the the
the the the people that worked in our
minds and our quarries all of that
wealth
none of it trickled up to will that's
right so we're left in this state of
poverty and I I'm not you know I can
angry about that
a great sense of sorry can we can
disagree maybe about the words that we
describe but to to to capture wheels is
past the important thing is what's gonna
happen in wheels his future and I don't
want to see in the 21st century what
happened to Wales in the 20th a rich
country that was left with a bitter
legacy of poverty we have huge potential
let's seize it in the in the weeks ahead